welcome to this video playing mac pet
from Norway let's see a pretty
substantial rating difference but not
much you can do about it enter quite
often even though I rated players do a
good job on 15 minute let's see what we
got here I am mum I want to try the grin
fault it's black but 9003 already hints
that he's probably yes not going for an
absolute main line okay but the group
thought would be d5 and yeah I somehow
don't expect him to play c4 but maybe
okay night 22 hmm yeah this might be
preparation for 4c 496 anticipates c 4
i'm going to take play Bishop to e6 this
is a line that I had um I've played a
quite often when i was still playing on
the king's indian is black yeah i played
the king's indian but only after g3 i
would play the gruene felt and get this
type of position sometimes
yeah that's interesting night c 2 nite c
2 e 5 is an online here it's not clear
what what about the default porn there
should be seven rugby eight it sets
possible I could take deform this is
interesting why can overtake d4 knight
c6 is the problem 96 this Quincy form 97
checking edge 8mm interesting looks very
active though look looks like an active
position the night only seven can be
really a guy can easily get trapped if
white however yeah took takes on d4 this
94 okay here i need to take on c4 handle
used to spend time on it and young if he
is not taking now it does not make any
sense I think 97 must be played probably
a move like be three for example i can
go go into now okay i can go quincy
fabric especially three hmm interesting
maybe b3 should go to a 6 ought to be
five may
if he takes King h8 Bishop e7 I mean
that looks really shaky
okay it's dropping back ha I thought um
but I thought I can I can detect this
night now put the Queen I'm just not
sure how with see 5 or b-five maybe be
five just taking this way for I can take
yeah this also keeps b7 protected and
they have rope t8 coming soon yeah I'm
even better develop this is a good thing
I didn't snatch a porn and I'm let's say
behind in development I even have the
more active piece placement at the
moment even roop d8 is coming quickly
the queen is not really good does not
really have a good square him it's there
where this is okay no need to
second-guess everything yeah now this
Queen must go to see to I guess I don't
really see a move besides that okay well
here i have i have Bishop f5 maybe you
will take yeah maybe pretty sure you
will take
mmm not clear not clear what my best
move this okay make them make it simple
keep it simple approach a very useful
thing to remember in chess and we all
tend to neglect that that important who
will keep it simple sometimes you just
spot something that is really too
interesting to not to not play it and
well there is an argument for for for
doing the interesting things but
sometimes the simple things are just
just the better moves okay well Bishop
b5 I just wanted on the long diagonal so
that the g2 Bishop has has a useful
opposition and now just play
consolidating moves this is a very nice
piece on d5 and I already have mine
extra porn that I can try to convert in
the end game
yeah it's not so easy to give white some
advice it's basically just opponent no
no particular compensation but some you
have the relatively best chance to draw
with the pawn down is so Luke end game
so maybe young white can try to exchange
some some minor pieces but yeah the
problem is that i also have a somewhat
better activity yeah the bishop on d5
especially is the problem yeah moves
like that at the end you need to play 22
to move the air you on rook now 94 is an
interesting both now sort of violating
the keep it simple principle but it is
some probably just good right attacking
g5 so there should be seven will create
and then Bishop g2 could be quite nice
but ok I will be one it is somewhat
messy no no just cervical keep it simple
the bishop has some problems anyway with
finding a good place yeah mother's you
can use this you can play but the
question is some what what happens after
night each five hmm it's not not so
great but ok I can I can do that
attacking be 2 again yeah well here i
can i can trade a number of pieces which
I really don't don't mind then I wonder
however I take on f3 isn't this
isn't this just a whole piece yeah it's
all B's also a bit of slow my
calculation here but i'm just taking two
pieces and he only got the g7 our bishop
okay so what's the easiest now probably
trade of rooks on the default white
resigns yeah well in a 15-minute game
it's really little hope with this piece
down yeah 95 I think already am it was a
bit bit of a mistake or the most popular
movie sb3 actually be three and then a
five which leads to a typically complex
middle game there's also this move which
is not bad we should be five Bishop f4
centralizing not so good now this I
think is just not not so great but the
computer is not showing Queen D forge as
somewhat irritating me yeah well there
also was 94 which is something to look
at I wasn't really sure about things he
should be seven maybe this is just good
right a computer wants to do III and
yeah the night I don't want to go here
this does not make so much sense it's
not so great yeah but just the screen
movies is just good I think and now
let's let's see took them but the
straight i think is very good for black
because I'm immediately threatening 92
and this will lose more material even or
allow me let's say after after this
allow me to to enter the position even
some check this kind of stuff is some
it's just a pawn for for no compensation
after two bishops in
k this means that the computer wants to
do this yeah that I didn't consider so
much but ok I understand the point you
get some selective night maybe go here
Jack bit of a strange position can be
irritating and practical play those
nights it should be good for black
really but I mean I've got a porn and
two bishops a bit bit much but not so
easy practically because this nights are
so annoying okay well this is what you
played and this is I think is just very
good I thought that for better worse he
needs to take here and try to justify
that but probably this is nonsense yeah
this is just trapped it should be seven
ruki aid yeah like it's just winning
here yeah this is what he did but this
is just excellent for black now just a
matter of choosing between many good
continuations this was a very keep it
simple approach but there also was maybe
c6 was possible but okay well this is
good it just trades Queens and black has
got perfect control over this position
yeah 94 was a strong move but I didn't
really want to do anything remotely
fancy here yeah I wasn't through what I
actually did not really appreciate it I
was only really thinking on this move
which after let's say he retreats
somewhere here what
square but I was thinking that this
might be bit unnecessary yeah and here
after this he needs to do that keep the
bishop but ok just gave up this this
night as well so it was a piece down and
upon down so on this essentially leads
to big trouble and term can only be
continued ready with the bishop c6 here
but not advisable in any way alright
thanks for watching